[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم توسعت الاعتصامات مساء الاربعاء
في البصره جنوبيه العراق استجابه لدعوه
التيار المدني للتعبير عن رفض ما سماه
منظمو الاعتصامات تجاهل رئيس الوزراء حيدر
العبادي طالب المحتجين اثناء زيارته
المحافظه يوم الثلاثاء نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقش في
محورين ما هي افاق التصعيد الحالي في
مستوى وطبيعه الاحتجاجات الشعبيه التي
تشهدها
البصره وما دلاله تفجر هذا القدر من
الاحتجاج على تردي الخدمات في واحده من
اغنى محافظات
[موسيقى]
العراق بعد اكثر من عشر سنوات هيمن خلالها
المكون الشيعي بتشكيلاته المختلفه على
السلطه في العراق جاءت احتجاجات مناطق
الوسط والجنوب والتي تمثل الحواضن
الرئيسيه لهذا المكون لتكشف حاله التردي
المريع الذي تعاني منه هذه المناطق من حيث
سوء الخدمات وتفشي البطاله واستشراء
الفساد في البصره التي تمثل واحده من بؤر
الاحتجاجات الراهنه ثمه غضب مما اعتبره
المحتجون تجاهلا من قبل رئيس الوزراء حيدر
العبادي الذي قالوا انه بدا في زيارته
الاخيره بدا مهتما بالنفط اكثر من اهتمامه
بالمواطنين ومطالبهم تقرير مريم
مبيش البصره المحافظه الاغنى والافق في
العراق على فوهه بركان قد ينفجر في ايه
لحظه في المحافظه الغنيه بالذهب الاسود
والتي تعد المصدر الاول لخزينه الدوله
العراقيه تستمر المظاهره ضد الفساد ومن
اجل توفير الخدمات الغضب والشعور بظلم
الحكومات المتعاقبه هنا اخذ في التصاعد بت
للمحتجين تنسيقيه لمظاهرات التي قد تتطور
الى ما هو اكثر في حال فشله بغداد في
الاستجابه
لمطالبهم الغى رئيس الوزراء حيدر العبادي
زيارته للصين وذهب الى البصره في زياره
غير معلنه طمانه العباد للشركات الاجنبيه
وحرصه على زياره حقل غرب القرن النفطي
استفزت بعض المحتجين واتهمه باعطاء
الاولويه للشركات الاجنبيه وليس لمطالب
الشعب بالاصلاحات خاصه وانه لم يحاول جبر
الخواطر على الاقل في محافظه فقدت ثلاثه
مدنيين قتلوا خلال المظاهرات السابقه
والزياره التي روج لها بانها لاحتواء
الغاضبين يبدو انها ستكون سببا اخر لمزيد
من الاحتجاجات حقل واحد في البصره مثل
رميلا يمثل 40 في من حجم الانتاج العراقي
من النفط الخام رغم ذلك تعاني البصره من
ترد شامل في قطاع الخدمات وانقطاع متكرر
للكهرباء تتجاوز درجه الحراره في الصيف ال
50 لذلك تنظم بعض المظاهرات
ليلا تعاني المحافظه من الفقر والبطاله
وملوحه مياه شط العرب وبطء تنفيذ المشاريع
الوزاريه المعلنه في المنطقه البصره وكما
يبدو ايضا ساحه صراع سياسي شيعي شيعي مخيف
وتحديدا بين كتله المواطن التابعه للمجلس
الاعلى بقياده عمار الحكيم وجماعه ائتلاف
دوله القانون التابعه لنور المالكي بالرغم
من محاوله كل طرف استقطاب المتظاهرين
والمتاجره بمطالبهم ثمت اصوات تقول نحن لا
نمثل اي احد ونريد اصلاحات
عاجله
نيزه واح لعنه الذهب الاسود في البصره
واضحه سياسيا واقتصاديا واذا لم تعجل
الحكومه في وضع حد للفساد فيها وتحسين
الاوضاع المعيشيه للمواطن وتوفير العمل له
قد يتحول الغضب الى نار ستهز اركان نظام
هو اصلا
هش نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه من البصره
الدكتور كاظم السهلاني احد منظمي اعتصامات
البصره من بغداد هشام السهيل النائب في
الرمان العراقي عن ائتلاف دوله القانون
ومن لندن الدكتور غسان العطيه استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والدبلوماسي العراقي
السابق نبدا بالبصره والدكتور كاظم
السهلاني الى اين يمكن ان تصل هذه
الاعتصامات وهذه الاحتجاجات في البصره سيد
سهلاني اعتقد ان السيد العبادي اخطا خطا
فادحا عندما فضل الشركات النفطيه على اهل
البصره فاهل البصره يلعن الساعه التي اصبح
النفط فيها موجودا بحيث انه هذا النفط
اصبح نقمه علينا وليس نعمه فثلاث اربع
اراضينا هي للشركات النفطيه ووزاره النفط
ولا نجد قطعه ارض يسكن عليها المواطن فضلا
عن الانبعاثات الغازيه ف الذي فعله السيد
حيدر العبادي وكانما هو هو يغذي النزعات
الاقلمه ونزعات الانفصاليه على اعتبار
اننا انه اشعر ان البصره مجرد بئر نفط
وليس هناك فيها موا طنين يستحقون العيش
مواطنين لديهم حقوق مواطنين لديهم مطالب
تظاهرات ثلاثه جمع اعتصامات تدخل يومها
الثالث عشر كل هؤلاء لم يهم السيد العبادي
ولم يرف لهم جفن ولم يمثل دوره بوصفه رئيس
الوزراء وبالتالي لم نكن نبعد عن مكان
تواجده سوى خمسه امتار فقط لم يكلف نفسه
ان يسمع المعتصمين لدرجه انه الغضب البصري
الان اعتقد كبير جدا و سيتصاعد اكثر وان
لم ي ينزعوا فتيل الازمه التي زادوها
اعتقد ان الامور
ستتصادم ولكن سيد سهلاني الا يوجد حد ادنى
من التفهم الى ان رئيس الوزراء اراد طمانه
شركات كبرى ان غادرت او قلقت على مصالحها
فقد يصبح الوضع اسوا في البصره وفي وفي
العراق
عموما وهل واهل الشركات النفطيه هي اهم من
اهل البصره يا اخي نحن منذ 40 عام لا
نستطيع ان نشرب الماء من الاساله ولا
نستطيع حتى ان نغسل وجوهنا فيه نحن منذ 40
عام المواطن البصري لا يجد فرصه عمل لا
يجد لا يجد سكن لا يجد احترام يا اخي الم
الانسان اهم من اي ماده اخرى هل ماذا ماذا
كفوا البصره مقابل ما تمنحهم النفط ما هي
المكافاه التي منحنا لها نحن تحملنا وزر
كل الحروب التي خاضها
خاضها العراق منذ ايام صدام والى هذا
اليوم كل الازمات وكل الحروب هي على عاتقه
للبصره والبصره تغذي اكثر من 90% من
ميزانيه ميزانيه الدوله هل جزاء البصره
واهل البصره ان يكون هذا التعامل معها ان
يزور الحيدر العبادي شركات النفط ويصف
امنها بالخط الاحمر وحقوقنا ليس خطا احمر
اعتقد انه ارتكب ارتكب خطا فادحا والان
الشعور البصري باجمعه بعد ان كان يقول ان
فوضنا العبادي الان يقولون نحن نرفض
العبادي لانه احتقر اهل البصره وبذا
التصرف الذي تصرفه في الحقيقه وجه اهانه
بالغه وجرح الشعور الشعور البصري وشعرهم
بانهم ليس مواطنين يحق لهم العيش وليس لهم
الحقوق الدعوه للمطالب
وهذا وهذا الذي حدث سيزيد بشكل كبير من
وقع التظاهرات التي امتدت الى الاقضيه
وزاد الى وصلت الى الاعتصامات وقد يصل
الامر الى الاضرابات والعصيان المدني اذا
اذا كانت الامور يمكن ان تصل يعني اذا
كانت الامور يمكن ان تصل الى هذا الحد
السيد هشام
السهيل الا يعكس هذا يعني تنامي للغضب يجب
ان يؤخذ بعين الاعتبار من قبل صاحب القرار
في
العراق نعم البدايه حقيقه شكرا لك ولضيفك
الكريمين واحييك واحيي ضيفي اهلا وسهلا
حقيقه الموضوع مختلف تماما انا سمعت من
الاخ السهلاني الموضوع ليس بهذا الشكل
السيد العبادي الغى زياره مهمه كانت للصين
وكان السبب الرئيسي ان يتفرغ لموضوع
الاصلاحات للبلد عموما والبصره بالذات
مدينه البصره نحن
كلنا على امل انه البصره تتحسن منذ تغيير
النظام ولحد الان للاسف لم يتحسن شيء في
البصره ولا زالت ال البصره تعاني من ابسط
الاشياء وهي الماء الصالح للشرب وتكلمنا
كثيرا في وسائل الاعلام حول هذا الموضوع
اما زياره السيد العبادي كانت فيها شقين
رئيسيين والشق الاهم هو موضوع المتظاهرين
وماذا يريدون هؤلاء وما هي مطالبهم
الحقيقيه والتقى بمجلس المحافظه واستلم
طلبات المتظاهرين واوعد وهو في البصره انه
سيقوم بكل ما كل امكانياته في خدمه البصره
لان البصره شريان مهم والبصره بالنسبه
للعراق شيء مهم وتكاد تكون من اهم
المحافظات العراقيه للطبيعه وضعها ومكانها
الجغرافي ايضا موضوع النفط اما موضوع
النفط وشركات النفط هذه مساله طبيعيه
يفترض انه اهل البصره هم يحيون هذا
الموضوع البصره بلا شركات النفط والعراق
بلا شركات النفط بالطبع سيعاني من مشاكل
كبيره هذه ايرادات النفط او شركات النفط
هي التي تذهب للخدمات انا اتمنى على
الاخوان وعلى الجميع ان يعطوا فرصه للسيد
العبادي هو اتى باصلاحات جديده ويريد ان
يقدم اصلاحات وهذه الاصلاحات التي بدا بها
لم تكن موجوده منذ العمليه السياسيه
الجديده ولحد اليوم لم نصل الى هذه
المستوى او لا نصل الى هذا المستوى من
اعلان الاصلاحات فنتمنى على الاخوان ان
يعطوا فرصه للرجل يعني هو لم تبقى لم يمضي
على موضوع اطلاق الاصلاحات سوى ايام
معدوده ليس بيده عص سحريه كي يقوم بكل هذه
الاصلاحات اتمنى على الجميع ان يضعوا
ايديهم بيد الحكومه وبيد السيد رئيس
الوزراء من اجل الانتهاء من موضوع هذا هذا
الاصلاح الذي نادى به هناك زخ كبير ضد
السيد رئيس الوزراء سيد سيل واضح ان ان
هناك استياء متراكم في البصره يعني ليس
وليد اليوم هو استياء متراكم ولكن عندما
تصل الامور عندما تصل الامور دكتور غسان
عطيه الى الاعتصامات
استياء ثم زياره لرئيس الوزراء يفترض ان
ان تهدئ الامور فاذا بها تؤجج الغضب
والاحتقان كيف تنظر اجمالا لهذا الوضع في
البصره
بد ما قام به السيد العبادي من محاوله
اصلاح فتحت شهيه العراقيين واكثر من ذلك
ازالت حاجز الخوف اللي كان مهيمن ابان
الحكومات السابقه من 2003 الى الان كانت
هناك مظاهرات كانت تسحق اما الان فهذه
المظاهرات بدات تعم والحكومه والعبادي في
ورطه ان قمعها فسيزداد الوضع سوءا وان
تركها دون استجابه حقيقيه وكسب واقناع لهم
سيكون هو في ورطه اخرى الوضع العراقي الان
هو في مخاض مخاض مري وقاسي سبب الرئيسي ان
الاحزاب التي قبضت على السلطه وبالذات
الاحزاب الدينيه وبالذات الاحزاب الشيعيه
الدينيه التي مهيمنه على البصره وعلى
الجنوب والفرات الاوسط فشلت في تقديم
اي خدمه لابناء هذه المناطق البصره تشكو
ان هي غنيه بالنفط وشعبها فقير الديوانيه
والفرات الاوسط هم الاغنياء بالحب
والحنطه والشعير والان سلموا الحبوب
والحنطه للشعير الى الدوله من خمسه اشهر
والان لم يستلم استحقاقاتهم فظهرت
المظاهرات اليوم في كربلاء تطالب بدفع ف
اثمان الحبوب اللي سلموها للدوله اضافه
لذلك مشاريع وهميه في المحافظات الجنوبيه
السرقه كانت عامه من كان يسرق من له
النفوذ السياسي بعباره اخرى من كان له
مشاركه بهذا الاحزاب اللي حاكمه في العراق
فالمظاهرات الان لما تسمع تيار مدني او
يرفعوا شعارات لا شيعه لا سنه وانما وطنيه
هذه كلها تعكس حاله
من الرفض للحاله اللي بها وهذه تمس كل
الاحزاب الاسلاميه الشيعيه اثين تفضل الان
قبل كان بامكان تفضل تفضل كان بامكان
الحاكم ان ي يغطي على مشاكله بالفلوس كان
النفط 100 وكسور دولار اما الان فهو بال
40 دولار المنشات ضعيفه الصناعه الغيت
نهائيا وزاره الصناعه لم تعد الا وزاره
السكراب وليست وزاره الصناعه هذا الوضع
كله بدون وجود اموال عند الدوله بهذه
الحاله لا يمكن يطفئ مشاكل الناس بالمال
لان المال ما موجود لا يمكن ولكن اسمحلي
اسمح لي دكتور اسمحلي دكتور يعني حتى لما
كان هناك مال الا توجد مفارقه يعني هذه
الاحزاب الشيعيه كانت تقول ان المكون
الشيعي كان دائما مهمش وكانه هذا المكون
الان يمسك بزمام الامور لانصاف هذه
الشريحه الواسعه في المجتمع العراقي فاذا
بالاوضاع تبقى على ما هي عليه ليس فقط في
البصره في الكوفه في النجف التي لها ايضا
حتى دلاله رمزيه يعني
ال مؤاخذه ال الزباله في كل مكان الشوارع
مكسره لا توجد طرقات لا توجد ارصفه لا
توجد اي شيء يعني كيف لا ماء لا كهرباء
الماء غير صالح للشراب كيف يمكن ان نفسر
ان الشيعي الذي يفترض انه يدافع عن
طائفته لم يبدو حتى طائفيا لم يفعل لها
شيئا
يعني هذا اللي تفضلت به توصيف سليم الان
السؤال كيف الخروج من هال المازق العبادي
يحاول وحسنا يعمل لكن العبادي لا يملك
القدره ان يحل الامور لان هو ينتمي ل حزب
هو متهم بالفساد وبالوضع اللي وصلنا اللهه
المشكله انه الان الاطراف اللي هي فشلت
تريد تصلح هل قادره ولذا تسارع كثير من
قاده الشيعه الاسلاميين الى طهران وهم
يجتمعوا في طهران وتحاول طهران ان توحدهم
وتلملم هذه تدل على مزيد من الضعف وهناك
اطراف شيعيه اللي تحمل السلاح باسم الحشد
وغيره تقول احنا الاجدر بح البلد احنا
نقدر نقضي على الفساد واحنا نقدر نسوي
الوضع العراق جنه اي وعود جديده للعراقيين
بهذا المعنى لا اجد لا اجد وضعنا الا نحن
في نفق مظلم مظلم كيف نرضي ابناء الجنوب
والوسط على وضعهم المزري الاقتصادي كيف
نحرر مناطق الانبار والموصل كيف نحل مشاكل
بغداد ويا الكردستان كل هذه مشاكل موجوده
في دفعه واحده الخروج منها بتقديري يبدا
بمراحل المرحله الاولى غضب الشارع غيي
نحتاج الى طرف او قيادات بشكل جبهه وطنيه
جديده اللي ممكن تستوعب هذا الشيء ن
والاستيعاب والاستيعاب ايضا دكتور ياتي من
محاوله فهم بالضبط الاحتياجات لان البصره
الان توصف بانها المحافظه الاغنى وفي نفس
الوقت هي الافقر نريد ان نعرف اكثر ونفهم
اكثر بعد الفاصل دلاله تكشف الوضع في
البصره ومناطق جنوب العراق عموما عن كل
هذا القدر من التردي عوده الى هذا المحور
بعد فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مازلتم معنا في هذه
الحلقه التي نتناول فيها ابعاد ودلالات
تصاعد الاحتجاجات في مدينه البصره
العراقيه ودخ ودخولها مرحله الاعتصامات
اذا كان الوضع في البصره دكتور كاظم
السهلاني سيء على امتداد سنوات طويله ربما
من حق اي مراقب ان يسال لماذا صبرتم كل
هذه الفتره ودلاله تفجر الوضع الان بشكل
خاص اولا نحن لم ننتظر الحقيقه نحن منذ
2011 كنا نخرج في تظاهرات ونخرج في وقفات
احتجاجيه كثيره لكن للاسف كان هناك حجب
اعلامي الاعلام الموجود في العراق اغلبها
اعلام حزبي لم يغطي تلك التظاهرات
والاحتجاجات ومن عندها حمله الغاء التقاعد
البرلمان التي خرجنا فيها باكبر اكثر من
عشر تظاهرات وايضا حتى الاعلام العربي لم
يعطى حيزا لهذه التظاهرات والاحتجاجات
وبالتالي تصور الاخرين انه انه كنا ساكتين
في الحقيقه لم نكن ساكتين اما الدلالات
فالدلالة انه الاحزاب عليها ان تعي انها
فشلت فشلا ذريعا في اداره العراق فمنذ
2003 لحد الان لم يقدم اي منجز لا على
مستوى الامن ولا على مستوى الخدمات ولا
على مستوى الصناعه ولا بالعكس انه كل
الامور تسير
باتجاه
تنازلي مثلا اضرب لك مثال بسيط انه اكثر
من 40 مصنع في البصره بمختلف الاحجام كانت
تعمل الان كل هذه المصانع متوقفه هذا الا
موداتها على الايدي العامله اضرب لك مثال
اخر الاراضي الزراعيه التي كانت ايضا مكان
جذب في البصره اولا للايد العامله وثانيا
لتحسين البيئه اغلبها الان في طور التجريف
واخذها كمناطق سكنيه اغلبها للمسؤولين
والسياسيين وبالتالي حتى لا اغوص في هذه
التفاصيل انه الاحزاب فشلت فشلا ذريعا على
مستوى العراق والفشل الاكبر على مستوى
البصره ذكذك الفشل دكتور دكتور سهلاني على
ذكر هذا الفشل هل لدى اهالي البصره شعور
بانه ضحك عليهم لان عندما يتصدر المشهد
احزاب شيعيه وبعضهم بعمائم سود ربما يشعر
اهالي البصره بان هؤلاء اهلنا وعشيرتنا
وسيكونون الاحرص علينا هل هناك شعور بانه
تم تضليلهم او الضحك عليهم بشكل من
الاشكال هذا الشعور موجود بكل تاكيد
لان الاحزاب سواء موجوده على مستوى الشيعه
وحتى على مستوى المكونات الاخرى كلها عملت
على تضليل الشارع ب تعزيز النزعه الطائفيه
كل كان يصور للاخر انه اذ لم ينتخب من هذه
الطائفه معنات الطائفه الاخرى ستكتسبها
وهذا التعزيز الطائفي لعبوا على اوتاره
مده طويله لكنه الان اصبح غير صالحا للعب
وانكشف للناس واصبحت الصوره واضحه الناس
تريد خدمات الناس تريد حقوق الناس تريد
عمل الناس تريد امان الناس تريد كرامه هذه
اللعبه اللعبه الطائفيه التي استغلونى
استغلوا الناس بها وخاصه البسطاء مده
طويله الان انكشفت ولكن رغم انها انكشفت
اسمح لي دكتور رغم انها انكشفت ما زالت
محل يعني مساومه سياسيه ان صح التعبير
وهنا اسال السيد هشام السهيل عندما ياتي
بعض انصار السيد نوري المالكي
ويقولون صبر اهالي البصره نفد ولا بد من
الاصلاحات ولا بد من ك نوري المالكي ظل في
رئاسه الحكومه ثمان سنوات لم يفعل للبصره
وغيرها اي شيء كيف يتجرا الان انصاره
ويطالب لعبادي او يطالبون غيره بسرعه
اصلاح خلل له
سنوات نعم بالنسبه للسيد المالكي هو كان
رئيس الوزراء بالنسبه للعراق اكيد ولكنه
موضوع المحافظات كما تعلم مجالس المحافظات
او الحكومات المحليه هي المسؤول
المباشره عن موضوع عمار البصره او غير
البصره من المحافظات الاخرى وكان المفروض
بهذه الحكومات التي التي توالت على حكم
البصره ان تقدم شيء ولكن للاسف وكما تفضل
ضيفك الكريم نعم هناك فساد كبير ضرب وهناك
حمايه من قبل احزاب موجوده في في تلك
الفتره ولا زالت موجوده هذه الاحزاب للاسف
غطت على هؤلاء الفاسدين وبالتالي لم يقد
شيء ل ال المسؤوليه سيد سهيل هل هذا يعفيه
من المسؤوليه ثمان سنوات ليس ثمانيه اشهر
ولا ثمانيه ايام ثمان سنوات لم يفعل فيها
شيء لم يفعل فيها شيء لا هناك كثير لا اخي
العزيز هناك مشاريع قدمت يعني احنا يجب ان
لا نقول الب يقول اهالي البصره نعم ما ما
يخالف احنا احنا ما يخالف خلي نكون
واقعيين انا لا اقول ان حقبه السيد
المالكي كانت نزيهه 100% وكانت كذا ابدا
وانا من دوله القانون واكلمك بهذا الشيء
نعم كان هناك فساد وكان هناك فساد مستشري
في عدد كبير من مؤسسات الدوله وفي محافظات
اخرى ولكن هل نضع اللوم كله على الحكومه
المركزيه لا ابدا الحكومه المركزيه خصصت
اموال لمجالس المحافظات وهي تتصرف بهذه
الاموال هذا هذا هذا الحقيقه المشكله
الكبيره التي نعاني منها اليوم ما نحتاجه
حقيقه الى وحده الكلمه واتمنى على الجميع
ان يعطوا فرصه للسيد العبادي لانه السيد
العبادي بدا باصلاحات جذريه بعيدا عن الا
وان انت كما تعلم هذه الاصلاحات ضربت
مصالح كثير من الاحزاب وهناك حقبه اخرى من
الاصلاحات ستاتي ستضرب احزاب اخرى
وبالتالي لم تعط
فرصه لا يمكن لا يمكن ان نستمر في موضوع
الاصلاحات و سننتهي للمجهول بعد اذنك حتى
لا ننتهي حتى لا ننتهي في المجهول نسال
الدكتور غسان العطيه في النهايه كيف
يمكن الخروج من هذا الوضع خاصه للبصره
ومحافظات الجنوب مستفيدين من تجربه
الماضي في غايه الاهميه ان سيد العبادي
بمفرده سوف لن يحقق العبادي تاخر سنه لما
قام بالاشياء الا بعد انتفاضه الشارع
بالذات الشارع الشيعي ودعوه المرجعيه الان
هذا الشارع له حق ان يشعر بالياس والمراره
وبالذات البصره لكن المشكله الشارع لا
يمكن الشارع يحكم لابد الشارع يفرز قيا
ونخب يحترمها الشارع ويتفقون عليه ابناء
الان المعركه هي معركه ابناء الجنوب كي
يفرز قيادات جديده او جبهه سياسيه جديده
تصبح طرف محاور الا انها تقول عند انا
اتكلم باسم هذه الكتل المختلفه هذه امامها
شهرين ثلاثه اربعه بس لا بد ان تظهر الشيء
الاخر الى الان العبادي ما يملك قاعده
شعبيه خاصه به وانما قاعدته هي ضمن حزب
الدعوه ولكن حزب الدعوه اما ينشق ويظهر
تجديد جديد وكتله جديده لان لا يمكن ترقيع
الامور بعد هذا الشق الكبير ما تسمع الان
في البصره او في كل الجنوب كن على ثقه من
معلومات المباشره ان هذا اقل ما يمكن ان
يقال واذا سمعت بالاخبار الاف العراقيين
يهاجروا الى ويض ويخاطروا بارواحهم حتى
يروحوا لليونان بقوارب غير سليمه هذا يعكس
المراره الكبيره بالعراق هذه لا تتم مجرد
بشعارات وعواطف من لا نريدهم لا نريد هال
الاحزاب الفاسده على الشعب العراقي وعلى
القوى العراقيه وبالذات الاخوه بالبصره
وبالذات من الاخ السهلاني ان يبداوا
يوحدوا نفسهم ويعطوا نموذج جديد لقيادات
تتحدث باسم مناطقهم لا يقعوا بنفس المرض
وهو الصراعات الشخصيه كما حصل اليوم لما
اجتمعوا ابناء الانبار في فندق وابدا
الصراع بيناتهم ليس بالكلام بانما
بالكراسي شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور غسان
العطيه استاذ العلوم السياسيه والدبلوماسي
العراقي السابق شكرا ايضا لضيفنا من بغداد
السيد هشام السهيل النائب في البرلمان
العراقي عن ائتلاف دوله القانون وشكرا
لضيفنا من البصره الدكتور كاظم السهلاني
احد منظمي اعتصام البصر بهذا مشاهدينا
الكرام نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه
الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء